Вітаю на уроці з алгебри 1О-го класу!
Мене звати Кононенко Владислав.
Темою сьогоднішнього уроку є:
«Рівняння дотичної до графіка функції».
Тож, згадаємо, що ми дізнались про
рівняння дотичні з попередніх занять,
а саме – про геометричний зміст похідної.
Похідна функції в точці дорівнює
кутовому коефіцієнту дотичної.
Отже, похідна функції f у точці х0
дорівнює тангенсу кута нахилу або ж
дорівнює k, де k є кутовим
коефіцієнтом дотичної.
Що ми можемо з цього дізнатись?
Насправді, цих даних нам вистачає
для того, щоб записати рівняння дотичної.
Отже, давайте запишемо.
Нам з вами відомо, що
k – це кутовий коефіцієнт
дотичної, це похідна функції в точці.
Отже, маємо функцію у = f (х),
і певну точку х нульове, в якій ми
будемо записувати рівняння дотичної.
Отже, беремо похідну у цій точці.
Це відповідатиме за
наш кутовий коефіцієнт.
Що ще нам відомо для того,
щоб скласти рівняння дотичної?
Нам відомо, що ця дотична
є дотичною у точці х0.
Знаючи х0, ми можемо знайти і у0.
Для цього достатньо підставити
наше значення у функції f від х.
у0 дорівнюватиме, відповідно, f від х0.
Отже, нехай, рівняння
дотичної приймає вигляд:
у = kх+b.
Ми можемо підставити замість k
нашу похідну у точці для цієї функції.
Замість іксів та ігреків
можемо підставити координати
точки, в якій вона дотикається,
а саме – х0 та у0.
Тоді ми зможемо з
легкістю знайти коефіцієнт b.
Підставляємо.
Отже, виражаємо наш коефіцієнт b.
Ми маємо тепер коефіцієнт
k нашого рівняння дотичної –
це f штрих від х0
та коефіцієнт b,
у0 або ж f від х0
мінус f штрих від х0 помножене на х0.
Звідси, ми можемо записати
наше рівняння дотичної.
f штрих від х0 помножене на х, тобто kx
мінус наш коефіцієнт: b
-f'(х0) х0 + f (х0).
Отже, отримали рівняння дотичної,
де відповідні коефіцієнти
позначені як f штрих від х0
та -f штрих х0
помножене на х0 + f від х0.
Рівняння матиме більш звичний вигляд,
якщо ми винесемо f штрих від х0 за дужки.
Отримаємо рівняння у =
f штрих від х0 помножене
на (х-х0)+ f від х0.
Отже, перейдемо до розв’язування задач.
На рисунку зображено графік функції
і дотичну до нього в точці х0.
Знайти значення f штрих від х0.
Дивимось на перший графік.
Маємо певну функцію, яка виділена червоним
та дотичну у точці, яка виділена синім.
Наша дотична – це пряма,
яка перетинає
осі абсцис та ординат
у точках (2;0), (0;2).
Що таке f штрих від х0?
Як ми з вами тільки що дізнались –
це кутовий коефіцієнт дотичної
або ж тангенс кута нахилу.
Отже, давайте спробуємо знайти.
Відповідно, кут нахилу у нашої дотичної,
яка перетинає осі у точках (2;0) і (0;2)
з додатнім напрямком осі абсцис,
буде, відповідно, ось цей кут.
Позначимо його як альфа.
Тоді цей кут
буде дорівнювати 180 градусів мінус альфа,
як суміжний з нашим кутом альфа.
Отже, тангенс альфа =
котангенс 180 градусів
мінус альфа зі знаком мінус.
За формулами зведення, тригонометричними,
котангенс суміжного кута
буде дорівнювати мінус тангенсу
або ж, відповідно, навпаки.
З прямокутного трикутника,
який ми утворили,
виходить 2 катети -  2 та 2.
Котангенс дорівнюватиме, відповідно, -2/2.
Точніше, сам котангенс
дорівнює 2/2, тобто 1,
а тангенс дорівнюватиме
вже -1, відповідно.
Отже, кутовий коефіцієнт
дотичної, або ж f штрих від х0
дорівнює -1 для цього прикладу.
Аналогічним чином
розглядаємо приклад номер 2.
Наша дотична перетинає
вісь ординат у точці 2,
f штрих від х0 відповідає за кутовий
коефіцієнт, тобто, тангенс кута нахилу.
У цьому випадку наша
дотична паралельна осі абсцис.
Що це означає?
Це означає, що вона утворює
разом з віссю абсцис кут 0 градусів.
Вони при накладанні будуть співпадати.
Тангенс нуля градусів,
відповідно, дорівнює нулю.
Отже, у другому пункті відповіддю буде 0.
Тангенс кута нахилу дорівнює нулю,
а кутовий коефіцієнт дотичної і
f штрих від х0 також дорівнює 0.
Переходимо до 3-го прикладу.
Аналогічним чином визначаємо,
як і в першому прикладі.
Маємо дотичну, яка
перетинає вісь ординат у точці 1
та вісь абсцис у точці -3.
Отже, кут нахилу – це
буде кут між дотичною
та додатнім напрямком осі абсцис.
Позначимо його як альфа.
У цьому прямокутному
трикутнику маємо два катети:
1 та -3.
Точніше, довжина його буде, відповідно, 3.
Отже, тангенс альфа = 1/3.
Протилежний катет до прилеглого.
Переходимо до наступних прикладів.
Отже, знайти похідну
функції у = cos 3х
у точці х0 = Пі/18.
Функція у = cos 3х
та точки х0 = Пі/18.
Функція cos 3х
це таблична функція і
знаходиться доволі легко.
Похідна від косинуса – це
буде, відповідно, мінус синус
та ми маємо коефіцієнт перед х.
Ми з вами розглядали
правило на попередньому занятті
при розгляданні похідних
складених функцій,
що коефіцієнт перед х
має винестись як множник.
Отже, у штрих = 3
помножене на мінус синус 3х.
Відповідно, коли ми підставимо х0,
то і знайдемо кутовий коефіцієнт
або ж відповідь до цієї задачі.
у штрих від х0 =
3 помножити на мінус
синус 3 помножене на Пі/18.
Розраховуємо цей вираз.
3 помножити на мінус синус Пі/6.
Синус Пі/6 або ж синус
30 градусів = 1/2.
Отже, відповідь до цього
прикладу буде півтора, або ж 3/2.
Перейдемо до наступного прикладу.
Знайти кут, який утворює з додатним
напрямом осі Ох дотичну до графіка функції
у = (1/4)х^4 у точці х0 = -1.
Отже, функція у = (1/4)х^4
у точці х0 = -1.
Потрібно знайти кут.
Для того, щоб знайти кут, достатньо знайти
його будь-яку тригонометричну функцію.
У нашому випадку достатньо знайти тангенс
цього кута або ж похідну у даній точці.
Похідна від функції х у четвертому
дорівнюватиме, за таблицею, 4х в кубі,
і множимо на наш постійний множник 1/4.
Відповідно, отримаємо:
1/4 на 4(х0 в кубі) = х0 в кубі.
Підставляючи наше
значення х0 отримаємо -1.
Отже, тангенс кута
нахилу буде дорівнювати -1
і за табличкою тангенсів,
синусів, косинусів та котангенсів
ми можемо дізнатись,
що це – кут 135 градусів.
Тож, перейдемо, безпосередньо,
до складання рівняння дотичної.
Ми потренувались з вами у
знаходженні кутового коефіцієнту дотичної
або ж тангенсу кута нахилу.
Тепер потрібно підставити точку,
у якій наша пряма дотична
дотикається до графіку функції.
Тож, перейдемо до прикладу 3.
Рівняння дотичної потрібно
скласти до такої функції:
у = х^3 у відповідній
точці, яка має координати (2;8).
Дані координати
відповідають за наші х0 та у0,
які підходять до графіку дотичної.
Отже, знаходимо кутовий коефіцієнт:
у штрих = 3х^2.
Це – похідна від нашої функції.
Для того, щоб знайти кутовий
коефіцієнт, потрібно підставити х0.
Отримали, кутовий коефіцієнт
нашої дотичної дорівнює 12.
Отже, рівняння нашої дотичної
можна записати в такому вигляді:
у = 12х + певний коефіцієнт b.
Залишилось знайти цей коефіцієнт b.
Для цього ми маємо підставити
координати точки (х0;у0) до нашої функції
і знайти коефіцієнт b
або ж підставити у формулу,
яку ми сьогодні розглядали.
Підставляємо.
Отримали: b = 8-24,
відповідно: b = -16.
Отже, рівнянням дотичної буде
пряма з кутовим коефіцієнтом 12
та вільним членом -16.
у = 12х-16.
Ця пряма є дотичною
до графіка функції у = х^3 в х0 = 2.
Переходимо до наступної функції.
Завдання аналогічне.
Потрібно скласти рівняння
дотичної до графіка функції:
у = х/(х+1) у точці х0 = -2.
Отже, функція у = х/(х+1)
і наша точка х0 = -2.
Яка складність цієї функції?
Складність полягає у взятті похідної,
оскільки ця функція не підпадає
під розряд табличних функцій.
Потрібно зробити певні перетворення.
Отже, наша функція: у = х/(х+1),
потрібно виділити цілу
частину даного дробу.
А саме, у чисельнику ми
додаємо та віднімаємо одиничку.
Для чого це потрібно?
Потрібно виокремити
такий доданок у чисельнику,
щоб він повністю
співпадав із знаменником.
Отже, ми маємо у
чисельнику такі 2 доданки:
х+1 та, відповідно, мінус наша одиничка,
і у знаменнику ми маємо х+1.
За властивостями дробів ми можемо
поділити почленно наші елементи.
Отже, х+1 ділимо на х+1,
отримаємо 1
і -1 поділити на наш знаменник х+1.
Для того, щоб було легше
взяти похідну – я запишу:
1/(х+1) як
(х+1) у мінус першому степені.
Отримали таку функцію.
Отже, наша задача зводиться до
складання рівняння дотичної до функції:
у = 1- (х+1)^-1
при точці х0 = -2.
Давайте перепишемо та зробимо це завдання.
Отже, функція перетворилась на
у = 1- (х+1)^-1
і у точці х0 = -2.
В чому полягає складність цієї функції?
Саме у взятті похідної.
Знов – чому?
Тому що (х+1) у мінус першому –
це буде складена функція,
де вона розбивається
на такі дві функції: f та g,
де f є зовнішньою функцією, а
саме взяття мінус першої степені,
а g є внутрішньою функцією (х+1).
Давайте розпишемо.
Відповідно, f = (х+1)^-1
а  g=х+1
Візьмемо похідну за правилом
взяття складеної функції.
Також за правилом суми, оскільки
у нас тут є, що 1 мінус дана функція.
у штрих дорівнюватиме: похідна від
одинички буде константою, тобто, 0.
Далі, похідна від зовнішньої
функції f буде -1, виноситься,
і разом з цим мінусом,
відповідно, буде + на нашу функцію,
і помножити на похідну
внутрішньої функції.
Похідна від внутрішньої функції, від
х+1, відповідно, дорівнюватиме одиничці,
і степінь у зовнішньої функції -2.
Отже, похідна дорівнюватиме
(х+1)^-2
Якщо ми підставимо нашу точку х0 = -2,
то отримаємо кутовий коефіцієнт.
Разом з кутовим коефіцієнтом х0 та у0 –
ми отримаємо рівняння дотичної.
Втім, звідки ми можемо взяти наше у0?
У нас є функція, яка має одну
спільну точку разом з нашою дотичною.
Це саме точка дотику,
тому, підставляючи х0
до рівняння нашої функції,
ми отримаємо, відповідно, у0.
Давайте це зробимо.
Отже, для початку, кутовий коефіцієнт.
Підставляємо х0 до нашої похідної.
Це, відповідно, дорівнюватиме 1.
Знаходимо наше у0.
Ми підставляємо х0 до
нашого рівняння функції.
Відповідно, дорівнюватиме
-2 +1= -1
-1 степінь нічого з ним не
зробить, воно так і залишиться -1.
Точніше, воно переведе
його до знаменника,
але 1 ділене на -1,
відповідно, дорівнюватиме -1.
Зі знаком мінус отримаємо +.
Отже, 1+1=2.
Отримали кутовий коефіцієнт, отримали у0.
Отже,
нехай, рівняння нашої дотичної
записується у вигляді: у=kx+b.
Підставляємо наші значення, у0, тобто 2,
підставляємо наше значення
кутового коефіцієнту, тобто 1,
та х0 -2.
Відповідно, знайдемо значення b.
Виконавши легкі алгебраїчні
перетворення, отримаємо: b= 2+2= 4.
Отже, відповіддю до
цього завдання буде у = х+4,
що є графіком дотичної до нашої функції.
Отже, перейдемо до наступного прикладу.
Потрібно скласти рівняння
дотичної до графіка функції f
у точці його перетину з віссю абсцис.
Маємо такі дві функції:
1) f (х) = 8*(х^3)-1;
2) f (х) = х – 1/х.
Отже, що ми маємо...
Перша функція:
f (х) = 8*(х^3)-1
Потрібно скласти рівняння дотичної у
точці перетину функції з віссю абсцис.
Що це за точка?
Всі точки, які належать осі
абсцис мають координату у=0.
Отже, підставляючи у=0 або
0 замість f (х), отримаємо: х0.
0=8(х0)^3-1.
Звідси, х0 в кубі = 1/8.
х0=1/2.
Отже, точка, у якій ми маємо
скласти рівняння дотичної, буде х0=1/2.
Відповідно, у0=0.
Знаходити у0 у нас немає необхідності,
оскільки ми його знали спочатку, з умови.
Залишилось знайти кутовий коефіцієнт,
підставити та знайти
вільний член нашої прямої
або ж рівняння дотичної.
Давайте це зробимо.
Відповідно, f штрих від х =
8 помножити на 3х квадрат,
-1, похідна від нього буде 0.
Підставимо нашу точку х0.
8 на 3 і на 1/4.
Кутовий коефіцієнт,
відповідно, дорівнює 6.
Нехай, рівняння дотичної записується
у вигляді: у=kx+b, добре нам відоме,
де k – кутовий коефіцієнт.
Підставляємо наші значення.
Відповідно, у буде 0,
k буде 6,
х0 буде 1/2
+ наше b.
Звідси, b=-3,
а отже, відповіддю до
нашого завдання буде: у=6х-3.
Тож, перейдемо до наступної функції:
f від х = х – 1/х.
Абсолютно аналогічна процедура,
ми маємо знайти наше х0,
для цього, замість f(х) підставляємо 0.
При розв’язанні цього рівняння
ми отримаємо квадратне рівняння.
Зводимо до спільного знаменника.
Це рівняння матиме
розв’язки при х^2-1=0.
Отже, х=+/-1.
Переносимо 1 праворуч,
х^2=1, відповідно, х=+/-1.
Що це означає?
Це означає, що наша функція перетинає
вісь абсцис у двох різних точках,
а отже, потрібно скласти рівняння
дотичної до кожної з цих точок.
Отже, переходимо до знаходження
кутових коефіцієнтів даних дотичних,
їх тепер буде дві.
F штрих від х =…
Відповідно, беремо похідну
від х за правилом різниці,
спочатку від х – це буде 1,
і похідну від 1/х або ж х^-1
це буде, відповідно, -х^-2.
Отже, +х^-2
Плюс, оскільки на нього діє ще один мінус.
Позначимо наші точки, як х1 та х2.
Для першої та,
відповідно, другої дотичної.
Отже f штрих від х1 дорівнює, відповідно,
1+1, це буде 2,
і f штрих від х2
дорівнюватиме, відповідно,
1+...
(-1) у -2 степені, дасть нам 1.
Отримали, що наші
кутові коефіцієнти рівні.
Тепер саме час запитати у наших глядачів –
а що означає, якщо кутові коефіцієнти
у двох прямих будуть рівними.
Варіант відповіді 1: прямі
будуть перпендикулярні.
Варіант відповіді 2:
прямі будуть паралельні.
Варіант відповіді 3: прямі
перетинаються під кутом 45 градусів.
Правильним варіантом відповіді є
варіант 2, наші прямі будуть паралельні.
Отже, нехай рівняння кожної з наших
дотичних буде представлятися у вигляді:
у=k1*x+b1
та у=k2*x+b2.
Маємо, що k1 та k2 рівні та дорівнюють 2,
також у=0, оскільки ми
шукали перетин із віссю абсцис,
відповідно, відрізняються лише наші х0.
Точніше х1 та х2, звідки ми і
знайдемо наші різні значення b1 та b2.
Перше рівняння дотичної, відповідно,
0=2*1+b1.
Звідси b1= -2.
Друге рівняння:
0=2*(-1)+b2
Отже, b2=2.
При підстановці наших, відповідно
b1, b2, k1, k2 у рівняння дотичної
отримаємо, відповідно, їх відповідь.
у=2х+2.
Та у=2х-2.
Це наші рівняння дотичної до даної функції
у її точках перетину з віссю абсцис.
Мені здається, що я чую дзвоник, а це
означає, що на сьогодні час завершувати.
Дякую за увагу, до нових зустрічей!